I HOPENOT THE LAST.
>> I HOPE SO TOO, WILL.
NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> Will: BATTLE FOR CRITICAL
RACE THEORY IN OUR SCHOOLS HAS
BECOME A MAJOR FLASH POINT IN
ONE PLACE IN PARTICULAR, GROUND
ZERO.
THE VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S RACE.
REPUBLICAN GLENN YOUNGKIN IS
WITHIN PUNCHING DISTANCE OF
CLINTON HATCHET MAN TERRY
McAULIFFE AND HIS SUPPORT FOR
PARENTS' INVOLVEMENT IN THEIR
EDUCATION IS A BIG REASON WHY AS
WE SPEAK YOUNGKIN IS HOLDING A
RALLY IN BURKE, VIRGINIA, IT'S
JUST WRAPPING UP AND
HIGHLIGHTING GOVERNMENT ABUSE
AND THE FAILURE OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AGO.
>> WHEN I'M GOVERNOR, I WILL
DEMAND AND WE WILL GET IT THE
REPEAL OF THE LAW PASSED BY
DEMOCRATS THAT ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO COVER UP SERIOUS
CRIMES.
NEVER AGAIN WILL RADICAL SCHOOL
BOARDS BE ABLE TO HIDE, BE ABLE
TO HIDE CRIMINALS IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
>> HERE NOW CHRIS RUPP POO,
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE MANHATTAN
INSTITUTE IN THE CENTRAL FIGURE
NEXT POSING CRITICAL RACE THEORY
IN EVERY AMERICAN INSTITUTION.
ALWAYS GOOD TO TALK TO YOU,
CHRIS.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE DONE SUCH A
GREAT JOB AT EXPOSING THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK AMERICANS ARE
RIGHTFULLY OUTRAGED.
THE QUESTION IS AT WHAT LEVEL?
WILL IT IMPACT THE BALLOT BOX?
WILL IT IMPACT SCHOOL BOARD
ELECTION?
THE CASE OF VIRGINIA, WILL IT
SWING THIS GUBERNATORIAL RACE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S TIME WILL
TELL.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE BECAUSE, AS YOU KNOW,
VIRGINIA IS REALLY NOW A DEEP
BLUE STATE.
BUT, WHAT I THINK THAT GLENN
YOUNGKIN IS SEEING AND WE ARE
SEEING WITH THE GREAT TREMENDOUS
CROWDS THAT ARE RALLYING TO HIS
SIDE IS THAT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY SAN ISSUE THAT POLARIZES
PARENTS, CONSERVATIVES OPPOSE IT
BUT ALSO INDEPENDENTS AND THEN
ABOUT A QUARTER OF ALL
DEMOCRATS, ALSO OPPOSE IT IN
SCHOOLS.
SO, HE IS SEEING A TERRITORY
WHERE HE IS MOVING FAIRFAX AND
LOUDOUN COUNTY WHICH VOTED FOR
JOE BIDEN BY ABOUT A 30 POINT
MARGIN ON AVERAGE THAT ARE NOW
SUPPORTING HIM BY ABOUT A 10
POINT MARGIN ON THE ISSUE OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
SO YOU ARE SEEING A HUGE 40
POINT SWING TO HIS AD VAN
DAMAGE.
THAT'S WHY HE IS MAKING IT THE
CLOSING THEME OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
IT'S TOO EARLY TO TELL WHETHER
THAT WILL BE ENOUGH.
HIS INTERNAL POLLING DATA MUST
SUGGEST THAT THERE IS HOPE AND
THERE IS CERTAINLY HOPE IN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PATIENCE ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
MOBILIZING TO FIGHT CRT.
>> Will: CHRIS, I'M FASCINATED
HOW PASSIONATE PEOPLE ARE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE.
I WAS TALKING THE OTHER NIGHT
AND A MOTHER CAME UP TO ME.
THIS WAS IN A SOCIAL GATHERING.
ALL SHE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WAS
THIS TOXIC IDEOLOGY AND MADE ITS
WAY INTO HER CHILDREN'S SCHOOL.
AND, CHRIS, I'M TELLING YOU
BEYOND PASSIONATE.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR FROM ME
ABOUT MASKS OR EVEN PLEXIGLASS.
WHAT SHE DIDN'T WANT EITHER.
SHE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
POISONING OF HER CHILDREN'S
MIND.
I'M FASCINATED TO SEE, LIKE YOU
POINTED OUT, A BLUE STATE HERE.
TERRY McAULIFFE HAS DRAWN
DRAWN THE LINE ON EDUCATION
PARENTS SHOULD GET OUT OF THE
WAY.
PARENTS SHOULD NOT BE
MANIPULATING WHAT HEIR CHILDREN
LEARN.
I'M SO FASCINATED TO SEE WHO
THIS PASSION DOES FOR POLITICAL
IMPLICATIONS.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT THIS FIGHT
IS REALLY NOT EVEN ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY OR NO
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT IS MUCH
DEEPER THAT I THINK MOTIVATES
PEOPLE LIKE YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
IT'S REALLY A QUESTION OF WHO
CONTROLS PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS IN
OUR DEMOCRACY, IN OUR SOCIETY,
AND OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
IS IT GOING TO BE THE
BUREAUCRATS AND DIVERSITY COME
SARS AND TEACHERS UNIONS OR
GOING TO BE AS GLENN YOUNGKIN IS
AUTHORITY POWER TO PARENT TO
VOTERS AND TO FAMILIES.
THAT REALLY IS THE KEY DIVISION.
DO YOU WANT TO EMPOWER THE
PEOPLE OR DO YOU WANT TO EMPOWER
THE PERMANENT BUREAUCRACY?
AND THAT'S THE NATIONAL FIGHT
THAT WE'RE SEEING PLAYING OUT ON
THIS SMALL SCALE.
I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE STILL HAVE THE
INSTINCT FOR SELF-RULE AND
SELF-GOVERNANCE AND I HOPE
THAT'S WHAT PREVAILS IN
VIRGINIA.
>> Will: YOU HAVE NOT JUST BEEN
REPORTING ON THIS YOU HAVE BEEN
LEADING THE FIGHT AGAINST THIS
SPREAD OF THIS TOXIN.
I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT THIS MOTHER ASKED
ME WHAT CAN YOU DO?
DO YOU TALK TO THE SCHOOL
LEADER?
I SAID THE PROBLEM IS IT'S A
GROUND UP PROBLEM AT THIS POINT.
IT'S TEACHERS AS WELL.
IT'S AN IDEOLOGY TAUGHT IN
SCHOOLS.
SO IN YOUR ESTIMATION AS QUICKLY
AS YOU CAN.
HOW IS THIS OVERCOME?
>> IT'S OVERCOME THROUGH TWO
THINGS.
FIRST, WE HAVE TO JUST GET IT
OUT OF SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE TO BAN IT AND ACCOMPLISH
IT.
ABOLISH
RIGHT TO EXIT FAILING
INSTITUTIONS.
NO CHILD SHOULD BE TRAPPED IN A
FAILING PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT
VIOLATES HIS SENSE OF CONSCIENCE
THAT VIOLATES THE VALUES OF THE
PARENTS.
EVERY PARENT SHOULD TAKE THE
EDUCATION DOLLARS ANYWHERE THAT
THEY WISH.
>> Will: RIGHT.
>> SCHOOL CHOICE WILL LIBERTY
PEOPLE, IT WILL EMPOWER PEOPLE
AND ACTUALLY DEPOLARIZE SOME OF
THESE NATIONAL FIGHTS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
>> Will: LIKE WE LEARNED, WHAT
WE HAVE KNOWN ALL ALONG VOTE
WITH YOUR FEET.
FREEDOM IS THE ANSWER.
GIVE PEOPLE THE POWER OF